hi everyone I'm Mindy Kaling hi everyone
um I'm Emma Thompson and you know we're
about to do the wired auto-complete
interview yeah
seamlessly something we didn't know
anything about until five minutes ago
ever heard of anything now it's a weird
to me it sounds like something's gonna
just come at you with electrodes anyway
and it might be that way let's start
what do you think the first one was
gonna say is Mindy Kaling a human being
who's Mindy Kaling as rich as I think
she is is Mindy Kaling real I was right
I win you do win I so win they think I
may I okay
uh yeah it is Mindy Kaling married yeah
no I am NOT very no she's no but she is
wearing a very nice ring on her wedding
finger is Mindy Kaling single who put
these questions together obviously it's
the same question it's a murderer who's
narrowing down all the information about
we want to find out my address
yeah he's Mindy Kaling related to
Priyanka Chopra no one's actually
thought bad have a I googled this just
so it would accumulate Google hints
about it would show up in this very
circumstance okay here we go
hmm who's Emma Thompson a day a Dave yes
moving on is Emma Thompson nice is Emma
Thompson in star wars
no no does everyone think you're in Star
Wars why do they think I'm in Star Wars
you know why this is true my agent
actually said to the last people who
were making the last star but I get very
confused because obviously this so many
spin-off few things yes and they said
well you know he said she'd be really
interested in being in Star Wars because
I've actually really liked Star Wars and
they said no they did it not in Star
Wars because they don't want me to be in
news Emma Thompson related to Vanessa
Redgrave no did people understand all
the time we had to see if Emma Thompson
was in Star Wars as do you know when the
young Jedi has lost their will to live
and they end up in a forest somewhere
and then someone appears to them to
teach them yes you would be great at
that yes or I could be Jabba the Hutt's
home
okay baby sees you Bonnie I would be fun
and you would like to wear that bikini I
can't squeeze those frogs for you when
is Mindy Kaling's birthday you see they
are narrowing it down you and 24th yeah
don't tell them the truth so tell me the
truth because they look up the records
and turn up on your doorstep
oh my goodness which Mindy Kaling
character are you
oh that's a good night played some real
characters yes yes you tell you though
which which Mindy Kaling character am i
yeah really
I'm the real-life Mindy Kaling I'm gonna
have one of my characters here come on
if these questions make any sense of who
legit Mindy Kaling voice and inside out
good question I played the character
discussed weirdo who did Mindy Kaling
baby said did I babysit anyone famous I
don't think I babysat anyone famous
that's a really specific question I
think it's part of the whole you know
trying to find out where you live think
I know what Emma Thompson do you know I
just have to point out it is that it's
extremely uncomfortable to keep saying
your own name it just feels wrong and
self-important so I just want to say
that like this what do you think I
actually know it's not true I don't look
like this I look like this after an hour
in hair and makeup study it came from
that's a great question I studied
wizardry obviously I started trying to
think that for a moment I studied
physics and international relations no I
didn't I studied English literature
English literature what languages does
Emma Thompson speak French Spanish and a
bit of Italian you do read we can amuse
in yeah but I don't speak German I only
do the accents of quite well what did
Emma Thompson writes ability yeah Nanny
McPhee
and then several things that have not
been made sensibility is real good Matt
that's very kind well I didn't write it
of course I'm Jane Austen wrote it all
right laser eyes do as
green play-doh you guys what is Mindy
Kaling's baby's name okay well this is a
little interesting it has to do with our
movie my child is branded content for
this movie theme I've heard changed her
name deleted my baby's name is Catherine
because it's my favorite name which is
also the name of Emma's character was he
it was weird because I read the movie
before I had the baby and then I thought
you know she's a very complicated woman
so to name your child after the
complicated character but it's just a
very complicated baby little B s yes I
said it was a really interesting story I
don't know how much that find out what
is Mindy Kaling like in real life witty
and clever and extraordinary okay you
can listen them okay I hope that was all
good things not crusty old it was your
address actually what has Mindy Kaling
written I written I'm the office I've
written for my show the Mindy project I
wrote two books and I wrote late night
that's it two books two bucks actually
I've written supposed to you have the
books I've written I wrote them I was
asked by Peter Rabbit to write some new
Peter Rabbit books yeah I got a letter
from Peter Rabbit with a half-eaten
radish hmm it was very clever of the
mouse because I would have done
otherwise I'll get them for you
for Catherine what is Mindy Kaling's
ethnicity why is she so why did she
wanna reach Coco's that's pretty pretty
where are you from we want to know my of
course the way that this is insight into
my brain and I'm like ooh we're so
interested but it's really what's
resinous because I'm probably weird and
look different to them but I'm like
they're obsessed with me I'm Indian
there you go what did Mindy Kaling study
at Dartmouth classics did you this is
very least favorite subject at school is
learning Greek well I my focus was Latin
not Greek I know yeah I know it's really
tricky a trick class it's more
absolutely when my favorite subject on
classics actually I don't know you do
classes
anyway we'll talk about this later does
Emma Thompson it's a short word think of
my words that far just so many bad
things sing you have a great singing
voice actually she don't think that
mapping the blood from her ears does
Emma Thompson Drake does love poached in
the boys I thought I was gonna say is
Emma Thompson Emma Thompson dyeing
her hair no I just have this
extraordinary sort of slightly pink you
know blonde thing going on does Emma
Thompson have an Oscar yes I do I have
two does Emma Thompson have children yes
I have two yeah great and I might have
to keep that actually because it sort of
defines me this sounds like a man
deciding whether or not he's gonna ask
you out on a date drink did she say how
she's given birth I'll have nothing to
do with I'd say what inspired Mindy
Kaling first to write comedy you know
what inspires her now what does she
think is funny what about how much money
absolutely
I've drunk it all away spent all of it
on my hair dye